okay so last class we talked about Maria
kutas who is an anthropologist and she
makes the argument that um for the
longest time for most of its history
Europe was he got
atarian peaceful and
artistic but
today we are um a
patriarchy um there's a lot of
inequality
and we're we're always at war with each
with each other so what changed okay and
um last time we
discussed um that Old Europe was
conquered by a warlike people who we
call today the yanah okay so three
questions I want to answer in today's
class is first of
all who are the yamaya second question
is
where do they come from the third
question is how do they conquer Europe
okay all right so let's go back um in
time and look
at the world uh about 10,000 years ago
okay so we believe that about 11,000
years ago in the near
East we develop
agriculture we develop the technology of
farming and as we discussed um in our
very first class it was because humans
are a religious people and farming
allows us to celebrate our religion okay
and the reason why farming was founded
in the near East is for the longest time
there's an Ice Age so you couldn't Farm
you had to move around from place to
place to hunt and find food okay so
after the Ice Age which ended about
12,000 years ago the climate became
warmer and the near East became the area
where you could grow crops the easiest
okay so near near near East is what we
call the Middle East today which
includes turkey Jordan Syria and Israel
that's where farming was
evented about um ,000 8,000 years ago
the weather became a lot cooler okay
there was another ice age for a very
short amount of time and this forced
people to start to immigrate or migrate
to look for new lands okay so people in
the near East they went off to
Europe and these people were very lucky
because the geography of Europe was not
that different from the geography of the
near East so they could take their
religion they could take their
technology move over to Europe and still
be about the same okay there were some
minor changes but they were more or less
the same okay so these people are very
lucky and these people as Maria kuta
said these people have the same religion
as people of the near East they worship
the mother goddess who gives life to
everything okay okay they believed in
the ideas of unity Unity just Unity just
means that we are the same okay every
one of us are the same we have a
responsibility to love each other and to
love each other's
children we're the same as animals we're
the same as plants okay so we must do
our best protect nature the Farms allows
us to eat food but we should not destroy
nature we should protect nature because
it's all the mother God is okay all the
children of the mother goddess um so we
also believe in balance and Harmony and
this is the religion as we discussed
pre4 of many indigenous peoples around
the world if you go to Africa
Australia um the Amazon and you meet
these IND indigenous peoples they have
the very they have the same religion
which is we come from a mother goddess
and we have a responsibility to protect
the nature the Earth because that's what
the because that's the gift from the
mother goddess and everyone has a soul
so after we die our soul uh still lives
on okay does that make sense guys so
this is the religion of Old Europe and
because of this religion they were
egalitarian meaning there was no real
difference between men and women in fact
because women have the power to give
birth to give life they were considered
in many ways
Superior um to man and the political
class was mainly governed by women
okay um they were peaceful they really
didn't have to fight each other because
they felt their resources was enough for
them okay and they're artistic so they
focused their intellectual energies on
creating art to celebrate the mother
goddess and their religion okay so uh
the people of the NES and the people of
Europe Europe were very similar okay the
problem starts when these people went
off to what we call the
steps the steps is a huge ocean of
grassland that basically extends from uh
Europe into Mongolia okay and you know
the Chinese word for this is tan now the
problem with uh the the grass line is
people can't eat grass
and you cannot grow crops on Grassland
that easily okay so the people on the
steps they struggle to
survive and um the people in the
steps engage in a process we call
social
Evolution okay so you may have heard the
term evolution I want to explain what
the term evolution means for our class
because we will refer to it a lot as we
progress through human history okay so
for us Evolution
means
open
Cooperative
competition okay so this is what
evolution means and evolution has
historically been the greatest source of
human Innovation and creativity okay so
let me explain why open means there's no
Central Authority there's no great power
okay there's no hedgemon everyone's
competing against each other competition
just means these
people um these many different people
they're trying to compete for to survive
okay there are very scarce resources in
the steps it's not as wealthy as in
their East and as Europe and they're all
trying to survive they all adopt
different strategies in order to survive
okay at the same time Cooperative means
they're still communicating with each
other they're still trading they're
still friends maybe uh they'll exchange
wives exchange presence okay
so this is a process of social Evolution
that has created the most innovation in
human history
so in Chinese
history this most resembles what period
in Chinese
history in Chinese
history which part of Chinese history
does this process where you have many
different people in open competition
with each other but still learning from
each other this period in Chinese
history is
called exactly right and that's the and
that's where most of Chinese Innovation
creativity came from from that period
confusious came from that period laa
okay a lot of major intellectual
breakthroughs came from that period okay
but not only uh the tun of
China as we move on we will also look at
two other major periods where there was
a major Outburst of innovation and they
have very similar social structure as
like this okay okay so we will also be
studying the Greek city
states in fact we will spend a lot of
time of uh on the Greek city states like
Athens and Sparta and and um thieves
because um before we actually F the
origin of w
civilization uh were the Greek city
states okay we no longer believe that
but for the longest time we believe uh
westernization came from the Greek city
states and when you look at the Greek
city states you will discover the system
they had back then is very similar to
this system
okay we also look at the
Sumerian city
states okay which is very similar to the
Greek city
states yes okay so um we'll be studying
these different um periods okay but I
want you to remember remember the first
important principle is whenever there's
an open Cooperative
competition tremendous Innovation
happens okay that's the first principle
I want you to remember the second
principle I want you to remember is
eventually someone triumphs in this
competition okay and the group the
people um that triumphs are the people
who are
Mo who are most open to
adopting
innovation in order to destroy others
okay does that make sense they're the
most ruthless in adopting all
Innovations for the sole purpose of
destroying others and becoming the so
hedgemon okay so we saw this with the
Greek city states where for hundreds of
years they were in competition with each
other and then there was a people called
the
macedonians who weren't actually Greek
okay they were
um um marginal to the Greek city states
and the Greeks didn't really consider
the macedonians part of their um
civilization but they were on the
outskirts and they observed all the
inovations that the Greek city states
were creating especially in terms of
military Innovation adopted all the
Innovations for their purposes and then
conquered the city states before they
moved on and conquered Persia and Egypt
okay and the and the leader of the
macedonians was called do you guys
know who was the leader of the
macedonians who conquer the the Greek
city
states I'm sure you know who he is but
you may not know he he was ma
Macedonian who's the most famous Greek
Greek you you've heard of
yeah he was actually Macedonia okay aent
of the
great
okay and what's amazing is we see the
same pattern play out with the Samarian
city states where for 100 years the city
states were in competition with each
other they were all trying to conquer
each other without success and then an
outside people a neighbor called the
aadia
the
acadians they adopted all the Innovation
and Technology of the saman city states
and then they conquered the saman city
states and established the first great
world Empire called the aadan Empire and
the founder of this Empire we will learn
is called Sargon the Great okay Sargon
the Great and Sargon the Great is
considered the world's very first Empire
bu
so even though we know almost nothing
about what was happening here from our
knowledge of the Greek city states and
the um Samaran city states and what
happened to them we can guess or
hypothesize the same process played out
here where these different tribes
different groups were creating all sorts
of different Innovations then one
outside group came in adopted all the
innov ations and then conquered everyone
okay so and these people are we call the
yaya who um originate we believe in
Ukraine okay so let's now discuss the
innovations that that these people
created okay and the Innovations were
pretty incredible because they forever
transformed human history okay so the
first Innovation they adopted was a
pastoral economy okay a pastoral economy
basically um raising cattle raising or
hurting cattle or
cows all
right so we cannot eat grass okay but
cows and sheep and goats can eat grass
and then we can eat the cows the goats
and the Sheep okay does that make
sense so what we realize what these
people realize is they can take the cows
the goats and the sheeps from the
farmers okay because there's a lot of
trading back then and then raise them in
the steps and because there's so much
grass they'll go very fast and then you
can use that as the source of your food
okay so they created a new
economy what then they what the second
invation is what then they realize is
you know what we we can also drink their
milk okay
Dairy and this is this is important
because for most of of human history we
cannot drink milk because we're lactose
intolerant okay in fact most people in
the world today are still lactose
intolerant but they develop the enzymes
the peptides in order to drink milk okay
they became lactose
tolerant so that's their second big
innovation the ability to drink milk
okay and now now if you're able to eat
protein and you drink milk a lot what
happens to your
body what happens to your
body exactly okay you become very tall
very strong okay so because of these two
to Innovations the people in the steps
were on average okay just average 20 cm
taller than the farmers in the near East
and in Europe 20 cm is a lot guys
Okay the reason why is the farmers did
not eat meat mostly and they could not
drink milk they e they ate
vegetables
okay so the third big
innovation is the domestication of the
horse the reason why is the grassland is
huge and they needed to travel huge
distances to trade to communicate okay
so they started to domesticate the horse
and it's very hard to domesticate the
horse because horses are train or horses
are programmed hardwire to run away from
humans right if they see a threat they
run away so this process We Believe took
at least 3,000 years okay but they kept
on trying because because the ability to
ride horses was very important for their
society and their economy
and so now they have the ability to ride
horses that's the third big
innovation then they invent the
wheel okay and why this is important is
if you have the horse and the wheel you
can create the
wagon okay if you have the wagon it
means you are no longer stuck in one
place you can move from place to place
and so this is what we call the nomadic
pastoral economy okay doesn't make sense
they're able to move from place to place
because basically what happens is you
have a lot of cows they're going to eat
all the grass okay now you have to move
somewhere else for the meet the
grass okay does that make sense now the
problem with this is what if you move
from place to place and the cows are
eating all the grass what
happens usually
conflict right because you are now
competition for what call grazing rights
grazing
rights if your cows go into a grass land
and they eat all that grass well that's
preventing other
people from going in and having their
cows eat that grass okay so now they're
fighting
over land and grazing Reds okay what
else are are now going to fight
over how about cows right
because um in this economy one way to
survive is to feed your cows what's
what's another way to
survive what else can you do in this
economy in this
world steal other people's cows right
does it make
sense okay so the protection of the
house um me there was a greater emphasis
on men okay so remember in this Society
in the near East in Europe these are
agricultural
societies um and for them What mattered
was lifegiving giving
birth and um maintaining a harmonious
Society so women were more important but
in this Society where there's a lot of
violence there's a lot of conflict men
became more important
okay so with these Innovations they
start to change their economy the
society and their religion okay
economy
society and
religion okay so in terms of the economy
the the first major change from this
Society is the idea of private
property private property okay because
cows are private wealth and you have to
protect that
wealth okay so that's the first major
Innovation the idea of private property
where this belongs to you and only you
and not to society or to the mother
goddess okay and that's very different
from the farmers in Europe who have no
concept of private
property um from the idea of private
property the society changes and becomes
a
patriarchy okay where men are in
control okay and the patriarchy of
private property the problem now is one
of inheritance right so let's just say I
have 10 sons and I have 100
cattle and I die who gets my
cattle who gets my
wealth it has to be the older son why
the Elder son
why exactly okay so we need 100 cattle
to survive as a family if I start
splitting the wealth up between the 10
Sons we be we we we become a lot poor
right the 10 sons have 10 Sons then then
by the third generation everyone has one
cattle so everyone's now poor okay so
the only way to solve this problem is if
I the patriarch the father give
everything to the eldest son okay and
this is what we call
primogeniture so this is a new
innovation
primogeniture where the eldest inherits
everything okay now the problem is what
happens to the other nine
Sons exactly okay so the Elder son gets
everything and the nine other Sons too
bad you you have to go build your own
wealth and that means basically stealing
cows from other people okay so this
creates a War
culture a War
culture right so does that make sense
that's your Society this is so society
which honors men above
women which um has private property and
celebrates private property which
encourages young men to go out and
expand their civilization and fight
Wars
okay so if you're making these changes
you now have to change the religion okay
the religion so their religion makes
major changes to the mother goddess
religion okay so the first major change
is who's now
God who who do they do they now
worship a man right because men fight
Wars so they worship they worship
someone called the sky father and he's
the source of uh who the Greeks call
Zeus the funer God okay and who the
Roman is called Jupiter also the funder
God so the first God is called the sky
father okay that's the first change the
second change is whereas the mother God
is gave us everything right
nature the sky father gave us cows
cattle money and wealth
okay so the Third change is whereas the
mother goddess asked us to love
everything and protect everything the
sky father asks us to fight each other
for the right to have wealth does that
make sense that's now their new
religion okay and so the they adopt this
new religion okay so these are all major
Innovations okay and again the one group
who comes in adopts all these
Innovations are call the
Yaya and so if you're a group and you
adopt most of these Innovations but not
all these
Innovations then you're going to lose to
the group called The Yaya who adopt all
the Innovations okay does that make
sense to you guys this what this is what
we call social evolution
okay and when they adopt all these
Innovations what happens is their
religion becomes aligned with with their
society which becomes aligned with the
economy okay and so this is a people who
are obsessed with collecting wealth and
fighting Wars and expanding into new
territories and so what happens is over
process of a few thousand years they
conquer the steps okay their culture
spreads throughout the steps doesn't
mean they're one people it means they're
one culture practice the same beliefs
okay does that make
sense any questions so
far so these are the yanah people this
is what they believe this is where they
came from this is how they behave next
thing I'm going to look at is fine how
do the these people
conquer Europe okay now I already
said they adni are stronger and bigger
and more militaristic than the farmers
of Old Europe right but what advantage
do the people of Europe have over the
yah what's the major advantage at Europe
P if you have farming what happens to
your
population it grows very fast right so
in other words
Europe has um more
population than um the steps does that
make sense okay so in theory okay well
yeah the Maya they have this warlike
religion um they're extremely
militaristic they're very strong but in
theory Europe could have withstood the
assault of the Amaya because Europe has
more people
okay so the question now is how did the
Amah conquer
Europe so what's a problem with people
who live on
farms what's their
ultimate
problem thank you the plague okay do you
understand because you're living next to
Pig PS and
rats and there's a lot of garbage around
okay so it's very easy for diseases to
spread okay so we believe two things
happen to reduce the population of
Europe significantly the first thing
that happened was the
plague okay and this wiped out entire
communities now the thing is though the
plague spread around the world okay
because remember what's important to
remember is these people in the steps in
the near East in Europe were all in
contact with with each other because
they were trading with each other okay
so this so the plague we know from DNA
research um was in Europe the near East
and the
steps why did it Wipe Out the population
of Europe but not the population of the
steps even though the plague was
everywhere
why the answer is because the people in
Europe were living in one place right
whereas the people the steps moving from
place to place does it make sense so
even though the plague did
impact the people in the steps the
impact was far greater in Europe in fact
we believe that most of the people were
wiped out by the plague in Europe okay
okay so that reduce the population
significantly okay so that's the first
thing that happened in Europe second
thing that happened in Europe is what we
call climate
change so about
um um
for sorry um yeah
about let me do the math about 5,000
6,000 years ago there was a mini ice age
in Europe
and if you're a farmer that's really bad
for you okay because you can't grow
crops and it's bad for you if you live
in the steps because a lot of your crops
will die but not as bad okay and the
other thing is that now the ice age
because of climate change people in the
steps are now forced to
expand further into Europe okay so this
this is what we we think happened three
things okay that destroyed Europe the
first thing is the play that's actually
the most important thing because it
wiped out most of the people okay so
think of when Europe conquered North and
South
America what killed most people in North
and South America was actually the
plague right Europeans had these
diseases they brought over and that
killed most of the local
population okay so the plague was the
main culprit that destroyed all Europe
then climate change and then finally
they have naive people people who came
into Europe and start to colonize Europe
and destroy the local population okay so
um let me now explain why the yah
decided to to
kill the
um uh people the farmers of Europe okay
so let's just say that your in Europe
you have a village maybe 100 men 100
woman you you have 100 men young men who
have no no wealth and no wives okay so
what do they want to
do if you're a young man you have no
wife and you have no wealth what do you
want to
do yeah you want to steal other people's
wife and property right so they came in
okay so and what what do they do you
have 100 men and 100 woman in this
Village so what do you
do no yeah but
yeah they killed a man okay guys okay
and then they married all the
woman and that's what happened okay now
there are some circumstances when the
came in because again this is a culture
this is not one people it's a culture of
people and they adopted different
strategies they some of them deci had to
come in and said listen we'll take all
the woman and we'll let the men go and
what did these men do in return in
response
what would you
do yeah so they went to get their
neighbors got a thousand of them came
back and killed everyone okay so this
was actually a violent violent process
with violence on both sides okay but
eventually what happened was the yah
conquered all of Europe okay and they
even got to
England they they conquered England
okay and then not only did they conquer
Europe then they went to conquer India
and
Iran so this spread
everywhere and even Mongolia okay but
not to
China what Why didn't it impact to
China what what what what are the
reasons why the Y could not conquer
China
what's between India and
China they conquered India right why
could they conquer
China you can't if you have horses okay
you can't cross the Himalayas okay so
that's what saved China the geography
also China had a huge population right
so even even if the came the population
could have uh repulsed the attack okay
but China did not was not conquered by
the yah so China for most of of its
history was isolated from the rest of
the world okay does that make
sense so but this Conquest meant now
there's a Common Language among all
these people in India in Iran in the
steps basically Russia in the near East
and in Europe okay this language is what
we call Proto indoeuropean that's a
language they spoke okay now they have a
common
religion so from this point
on this world okay stretching from
Europe all the way to India was in
constant communication from was in
constant communication with with each
other trating
ideas uh people and gods okay and this
is what we call today the West
okay and it's distinct from China which
was isolated from this world okay does
that make
sense okay any
questions
yeah um the Mongolian people are
descended from the yah yes and if you
think about it the Mongolian people are
very similar to the yah right the
Mongolian are also uh nomadic pastoral
people who are also very much warlike
okay and in fact what we will learn
later on is that gangas
Khan adopted very similar policies as
the Amah okay so we'll see a lot of
similars between uh gangas Khan and his
Conquest the am conquest of the world um
at this time about four or 5 thousand
years ago
yes the plague
yes it it killed most Europeans yes
because Europeans were living on farms
right so they were they were living
together
yeah because it reduced the population
of Europe so they were less able to
resist
Invasion okay all right so the plague
was all around the world okay um the and
this this is actually the banic plague
okay the banic plague um it's spread by
rats and we have D DNA of this plague
okay so we know the bank plague has been
with us for the longest time okay
um
so the plague kills people who live
closely
together you
understand because then it's easier to
transmit the the
disease okay so if you live closely
together you're much more likely to
catch the disease and die does it make
sense but if you live far apart then
you're less likely to catch the the
disease so in Europe people were living
on
farms and there's like 10,000 people who
might live on a farm okay that's a lot
of people who live very closely together
they're also living with animals so it's
very
unclean but if you're living in the
steps okay um first of all you're living
far apart that's the first thing second
thing is um you're you your life is much
more hygienic okay because you're not
living with pigs and rats
the third thing is your body is a lot
stronger you're drinking milk okay
you're getting a lot of physical
exercise does that make sense so these
people are less likely to die for the
plague all right any more
questions so are
the exactly yes okay so basically um
everyone in Europe except for few few
people are the descendants of the yah
okay the Indian people people the
Iranian people also consider descendants
of the
yaya now um when the
came these farmers in Europe okay um
there were maybe three major responses
okay the first response is let's fight
them and then they got killed the second
response is let's try to cooperate with
them okay the third major response is
let's move somewhere else so um the
people who move to Islands okay so for
example there's an island called sard
sard Sardinia okay in Italy okay it's an
island they survived against they
survived against the Yaya and they have
less Yaya DNA than um other people okay
but if you can't run off to an island
you're going to get wiped out okay but
basically all Europe was conquered by
the yah and when you look at the and
later on I will show you the DNA
evidence when you look at that evidence
it's pretty Stark
okay all right
how that's a great question okay thank
you all
right so the this process took a long
time hundreds of years okay and during
this time this is a spread of a culture
so it's not one people it's not one
nation so what's happening was as they
conquer different territories they had
they had to adapt themselves to that
territory
because the geography is different okay
so in the steps you're leading a nomadic
pastoral lifestyle and at first they
tried that so for example we have
evidence that in Norway which is in
North Europe they burn out all the
forest because they were trying to
replicate their Homeland okay but but
then eventually they discovered this is
not going to work okay it's too hard so
then they start to mix their lifestyle
with a local lifestyle and they became
um more focused on agriculture okay does
that make sense all right and as it kept
on spreading they also stole the
technology of the local people so even
though the Y people had no um ship
building technology they couldn't sell
the
Seas they were able to conquer people
here off the coast who did have access
to the Sea and who did have boats okay
and then they stole the technology they
killed the people and they learned the
technology okay once once they had the
technology then they sell off to England
and killed everyone in England does that
make sense okay so it's a very slow
process and these are different groups
of yah
okay okay but that that's a very good
question any more
questions are you guys clear about this
okay all
right absolutely clear okay good so
um
so when we get come back from the break
okay we will discuss the new world that
this
creates okay because when you think of
question civilization the Greeks the
Romans well they all come from this
world okay so basically what the do is
they create a new history for Humanity
before theah humans were egalitarian
peaceful and artistic okay and now with
the Amaya you have patriarchy you have
War you have money but before we didn't
have these Concepts so this marks a new
history for Humanity when we come back
from the briak we'll start exploring
this
history okay